Frozen warmed enough hearts that critics and
young audiences alike just couldn't seem to
let it go.
Luckily for Disney, it looks likes critics
are mostly feeling the same way about the
film's upcoming sequel, Frozen II.
The long-anticipated follow-up to what was
once the highest-grossing animated movie of
all time had its star-studded premiere in
Los Angeles on Thursday, November 7.
A movie six years in the making, the latest
enchanting adventure of sisters Anna and the
Snow Queen Elsa saw Hollywood creatives and
entertainment critics come out in droves to
get the first look at the film.
While the enchanting fantasy flick — which
follows the sisters as they and their friends
travel far from the kingdom of Arendelle to
find the source of Elsa's powers — isn't
slated for release until November 22nd, critics
in attendance have already taken to social
media to share their initial reactions.
And it all seems to point to yet another animated
hit for Disney.
“You can't just follow me into fire."
"Then don't run into fire."
The general consensus from those with premiere
invites point to a follow-up that's creatively
competitive with the original, a film that
quickly became both an award-winning animated
classic and pop cultural phenomenon.
Frozen II's songs and visuals especially have
received considerable praise.
Mashable deputy entertainment editor Angie
J. Han acknowledged that the Frozen sequel
exists in part simply because of the financial
success of the first film.
Still, Han said that doesn't take away from
what the second installment does right.
Among these things are new songs and an adorable
new character.
Jason Guerrasio, Business Insider's senior
entertainment reporter, called Frozen II "a
worthy sequel" that offers up some truly amazing
animation.
He added:
"Elsa rides a water horse and it's breathtaking.
The song 'Into the Unknown' is primed to be
'Let It Go'-like addictive (sorry parents)."
When the social embargo for Frozen II lifted
after the film's screening, critic Clayton
Davis took to Twitter and shared how profoundly
impacted he was by the film's messages, particularly
as a father watching with his daughter.
"#Frozen2 embarks as not just an evolution
of its characters, but it sincerely acknowledges
that its fanbase has grown over the last
6 years, and they have new things to learn
in a changing world.
Songs are plentiful.
Beautiful shots at times.
It was something I REALLY needed."
It's a level of emotional resonance Alisha
Grauso, an editorial lead at Atom Tickets,
said actually brought her to tears.
Part of that emotional reaction was due to
the film's focus on female empowerment, for
which the original was also praised.
She tweeted after seeing the film,
"#Frozen2 is breathtakingly beautiful and
leans in on empowerment for its characters.
I cried at least 3 times.
From the story to the last thread on Elsa's
dress, the care and love put into it shows.
And, good news, every one of Team Elsa gets
at least one solo this time around."
“I might cry.”
“Go ahead, I won't judge."
The DisInsider's editor-in-chief Skyler Shuler
went perhaps the farthest of any other journalist,
proclaiming that the Elsa, Anna, Kristoff,
Olaf, and Sven reunion was better than the
record-smashing Frozen.
Schuler even provided a warning for parents
who are still getting over the infectious
love of "Let It Go."
"I can't believe I am saying this, but FROZEN
2 is better than its predecessor.
Darker, a little more mature, but still an
excellent film for families, the songs believe
it or not are catchier, so parents beware."
Still, some critics have noted that Frozen
II's plot and other elements simply don't
stand up to those of its predecessor, although
they don't have a completely flipped opinion.
"Wait, what am I looking at right now?
Why are you hanging off the earth like a bat?"
Among the critics who have been, well, more
critical of Frozen II is Alison Foreman.
Another Mashable reporter in attendance at
the premiere, Foreman gave the film props
despite it not having the same magic of the
first movie, at least in her eyes:
"Just got out of #Frozen2!
It doesn't capture all the magic of the first,
but it's got: Elsa in a wetsuit, Anna ugly
crying, Sven ugly crying, Kristoff singing
a '90s rock ballad, Olaf at his wisest, and...
THIS GOOD BOY!!
(We must protect him at all costs.)"
For critics like Scott Menzel, the editor-in-chief
of We Live Entertainment, Frozen II couldn't
quite reach the quality delivery of the 2013
movie.
"Frozen 2 loses some of the magic of the original
but its soundtrack is surprisingly superior.
Kristoff, Sven, & Olaf standout even though
the script leaves Anna & Elsa out in the cold.
It is a decent sequel but definitely a step
down from the first."
Ashley Menzel, who's part of the Los Angeles
Online Film Critics Society, echoed those
feelings, stating that the animated production's
shift in its target demographic actually hurts
the movie:
"Frozen 2 creates musical magic, but story
wise, doesn't quite reach the level of the
original.
Olaf is certainly the highlight of the film
& brings much needed levity to a pretty dark
film.
It feels like it is for a much older crowd
than the target demo."
"Ooooh that's a rough business to be in right
now.
I mean, that is really… that's unfortunate."
Still, almost all the reviews find something
to praise about the film, and it sounds like
Disney just might have another billion-dollar
box office smash on its hands.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.